- (audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Have a seat.
Oh my God.
I like your Pumas.
I like your shoe wear.
- Yeah, yeah.
My daughter picked my outfit out today.
- [Kelly] Your daughter
picked your outfit out?
Because Maven's here with you, right?
- Yeah, she is.
- I'm very excited about that.
I'm very excited.
Do you remember the first time we met?
- We were on Saturday Night Live.
I was the host and she
was the musical guest.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And that's when I knew I had arrived.
(Kelly and the audience laughing)
Kelly, right?
They said
"You're hosting and Kelly's
going to be the musical guest."
I said, what!
(Kelly laughing)
It was great.
- I was freaking out.
- [Tracy] You?
I was such a fan.
- [Tracy] You was freaking out?
I was too.
- I was freaking out and
I think in that night too,
I was so, like, just caught off guard.
It's so late.
You don't realize like it's so late
when you're performing live, obviously.
And like, I remember I changed
the lyrics to 'Breakaway'.
It was like, "All I wanted was horses."
(audience laughing)
- No it's live TV.
- All I wanted was horses
and I was like, what?
- [Tracy] But Kelly, you realized that
doing live television is like
being shot out of a cannon.
Like literally, you're in front of
20 million people performing.
And if you're not Michael
Jackson, that's like, oh.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Kelly] Yes.
That's why I talked about horses,
apparently.
But you have a lot of nicknames
for late night hosts, like.
- [Tracy] For David Letterman,
I called him D-Nice, or
D-Lo for David Letterman.
I called Jimmy, Jim Bo.
I'll call Conan C-Black.
And then you have a name.
I gave you a name.
You are
KC or K-Whizzy.
- [Kelly] I like K-Whizzy!
- I'm calling you K-Whizzy.
- I like K-Whizzy.
- [Tracy] K-Whizzy.
- I like K-Whizzy,
- [Tracy] But when I say K-Whizzy,
that's when you gotta throw your swag on.
Yo, what up Tray?
- [Kelly] Oh, wait.
Maybe I should just be KC.
- I'm not cool
- Let me see you do it.
- I'm not cool.
- Yo, K-Whizzy, say it.
- Yo K-Whi-
I can't do it.
- [Tracy] No, do it!
Come on.
She got it though, right?
- Yo, K-Whizzy is in the house!
(audience applauding)
- [Tracy] Now, I gotta tell you,
now that I gave you the handle,
you're platinum.
Your ghetto card is platinum stamp.
- Validated.
- So you go into the Bronx,
Harlem, you can walk freely.
- [Kelly] Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
I'm still probably going to stick with KC.
But you're amazing.
You love animals like me.
I heard about this.
So what animals do you own right now?
- Well, I have,
well they're my daughter's animals.
She has a shark tank,
a 15,000 gallon shark tank.
- [Kelly] What?!
- [Tracy] And she has cone snails.
- What?
- A cone snail,
there's seven seas in the world.
A cone snail is the most
dangerous thing on the planet.
I mean, it could one this little snail,
this little thing can kill a blue whale.
- Okay so, the foreshadowing
with your daughter,
Maven is unreal.
You've got sharks.
Deadly.
Cone snails.
- She has lizards, whatever.
She'll tell you.
She has a dog.
She tell you everything that she has.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
I love it.
I love animals.
We always had,
I felt like I lived on a farm.
We lived in a tiny apartment.
All three of us at one point my siblings,
we shared one room,
but my mom still had
like dogs, guinea pig,
like everything else
had like a lot of room.
- Well that's what brings
you closer to nature.
- Yeah, I love it.
I love animals.
Your daughter Maven is
eight years old now.
So she's here with you right here, right?
- [Tracy] Yep.
- [Kelly] Hi Maven.
You want to come down here?
You want to sit with your dad?
- [Tracy] Come down here with your father.
- [Kelly] Look how cute you are!
Oh my gosh, can I have a hug?
You look so you look so beautiful.
You look so so cute.
I love that dress.
I love your shoes.
- This is my stink-mama.
She the reason why I came out that coma.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- [Tracy] She was only 10 months old
when I got hit by that truck.
- Wow.
It was that long ago, wow.
- [Tracy] I had to fight.
I gotta be here for her,
I gotta be here for her.
So when she's older and she say,
daddy, how do I know if he the one?
Well do he love you like me?
No.
Well then he ain't the one.
(audience cheering)
Cause I'll gladly lay my
life down for this one.
This my daughter.
- [Kelly] So, wait.
Can you tell me more about
your relationship with Maven?
Because I know you had boys, right?
- [Tracy] One of a kind.
- Maven was the last, right?
Yeah, but my daughter's my daughter.
I love my sons.
They're a product of me.
My sons are my kids.
But this one right here is my daughter.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Oh man.
I feel sorry for whoever you end up with.
- As long as he represent,
as long as he love her like I love her,
then he good with me.
- Okay, okay.
- [Tracy] He's good.
- Oh my gosh.
I would be scared.
- [Tracy] Other than that,
I got a baseball bat with his name on it.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- So wait, Maven you've also,
was she in the first episode?
Of your show?
- [Tracy] Yeah, she's
in the first episode.
She's all throughout the whole season.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's amazing!
I just heard that the first
episode that you were in,
like, how did it feel
to work with your dad?
- [Maven] Good.
- Yeah.
Was it fun?
- [Kelly] Or was it
kind of nerve wracking?
- It was fun.
I got all my lines correct.
- Oh my gosh.
Way to go.
(audience cheering)
- [Tracy] Yo, she dropped one line.
She dropped one line
and yelled out "line!"
- [Kelly] Saying line
at such as young age.
Did you guys have fun in the pandemic?
Cause I hear your house is like a party.
You have like a bowling alley?
- I have a bowling alley.
I have a Dave & Buster's for her.
Everything is for her.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh,
I love Dave & Buster's.
- [Tracy] Everything is for my daughter.
Dave and Buster's,
she has video games down there.
Big arcade games and we go down there.
And then I turned the whole basement
into a haunted mansion for her.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- She, you know, the struggle is real.
The struggle is real.
I don't care if you own Amazon,
everybody need a reason to
get out of bed in the morning.
That's the hardest part of
the day is getting out of bed.
What's yours?
This is mine.
- I love that!
She inspires me.
Get out and go get that bag.
That bag of money.
- [Kelly] I'm wondering,
I'm wondering if your sons are like,
they run to you, Maven
and go you should ask for this.
Like, you know?
Because they know you're going to get it.
That's what your son.
My, actually, my daughter does that
with my five-year-old son.
She's seven.
And if I say no to her,
she'll go to my son and she'll be like,
you should go ask mom if
we can go to see a movie.
And he'll come in and he'll be like,
it's like he's reading a script.
He's like, Oh mom, you
know what sounds fun?
Would be to go to the movies.
And I'm like.
I'm like what?
- Your sister asked you to say that?
- I know.
I'm like, did River just
tell you to come in here?
It's an amazing thing.
Your brother should look into that.
But what's your favorite
thing to do with your dad?
- Watch funny videos.
- [Kelly] Watch funny videos?
Oh, like on YouTube?
Do y'all watch like that
kind of funny video?
Yeah?
- Yo, we sit there and we
watch those videos all day long
or we'll watch American idol.
The tryouts and all of that.
- [Kelly] Oh Okay.
Never heard of it.
- [Tracy] You never heard of it.
(audience clapping)
- Wait, then you should watch
the blinds on The Voice too.
Those are fun too,
to see who turns around.